good morning believe nation my name is
Evan Carmichael my one word is believe
and I believe that entrepreneurs are
going to solve all of the world's major
problems so to help you on your journey
we're going to learn today how to follow
your dreams
over to you Erin Murray no I met a woman
that I helped lose a hundred pounds and
she came to me and said hey I want to
start a fitness center this for me was
my dream and it was tough well I didn't
make much money it didn't matter because
I was happy I was doing something I
loved
we took some loans and got some some
investors there was a big issue with
with one of our investors and my
business partner and it ultimately ended
up in lots of legal fights and battles
we had to end up shutting down this
business I was dead broke I was bankrupt
in order to make ends meet I was driving
a beer cart at a country club and I'm
sitting there with tears rushing down my
face because I don't know where to go I
was at the lowest point that I ever have
been giving up was never an option the
problem was that I didn't know what
success looked like anymore but what I
do have is a dreaming and desire to help
people
at the time there really wasn't anything
any resources out there for regular guys
they get some solid basic advice on how
to look good and feel great I decided
that I was going to help men feel better
and amazing about themselves so I have a
video camera I was the least tech savvy
person you'd ever meet but I picked it
up and I decided that I was going to try
and film a video and put it on YouTube
everything changed for me I found that
new vision I found that new passion all
the sudden I had a voice I had an
audience and I was doing something that
made me feel incredible because I
realized I was doing something to help
other people most people quit on their
dreams too soon they just quit too soon
you don't realize that the how success
you have to try and try and try and try
and keep improving and keep trying to
find another way until you eventually
hit it and that's the story of any
successful person they tried so many
different ways until they had the thing
that helped them break through and too
many quit way too quickly and you need
to explore and say yes and try things
until you find that thing that makes you
come alive and so for airing it was
YouTube he tried all this other stuff
and nothing was working and he knew he
had something bigger in them and he
didn't want to play the sea flight right
he didn't want to take that failure and
then say okay it's just not going to
work I'm going to go and work at a
retail store right you didn't give up on
doing something bigger even if we didn't
quite even know what that bigger thing
was he didn't give up most people quit
right there you need to continue to
explore he stumbled into YouTube and
that became the thing that he then
exploded with for me it was going to the
YMCA and delivering a speech that was
super proud of the go and help
entrepreneurs when they invited me in
and only three people showed up you know
three people showed up to a free event
how is that ever going to turn it into a
business I make money from it but
because I went and because I loved it
and because I enjoyed I had to find a
way to keep going even if I never made
money from it I had to find a way to
keep doing it because I loved it because
it became my dream because the feeling
that I got when I was doing it was
intoxicating I couldn't wait to go and
do it again I just found this thing and
that helping entrepreneurs was something
I found so satisfying and so I had to
find the way to continue and that's the
thing with dreams a lot of times they
don't make sense at the beginning you
don't quite know how it's going to work
out you don't necessarily have that
final end goal yet because it's brand
new because you haven't done anything
yet and so you've got to figure it out
you won't get to that success by sitting
on the couch and thinking and thinking
and thinking and thinking and seeing
other people make a lot of money and
other people going off and chasing their
dreams you have to get off the couch and
do something people often ask me when do
you quit and I'm not the guy who says
never never quit
the answer comes down to is this still
your dream or not are you still
passionate about this thing or not if
it's still your dream and you just
haven't figured out a way to make it
happen yet then you have to keep going
you have to keep doing it like Aaron and
the transition to youtube you have to
find different options and keep testing
and see the final thing that's right for
you the alternative is you're going to
live the rest of your life in regret
you're going to think I wish I just gave
a little bit more I wish I tried a
little bit harder I wished I pushed more
on this thing to make it work and you
settled for an average life but if you
don't have the passion anymore if it
just feels like work to you that's when
you quit it was not your dream anymore
then you quit and you move on to the
next thing that is your dream so the
question of a today is I'm curious what
is your dream leave it down the comments
below I'm really curious to find out
write it with some passion with emotion
with feelings that when you read it back
you're like yeah that's what I'm doing
I'm pumped about it let me see what you
got leave it in the comments I also want
to give a quick shout out to Eric's
array from 3s mobile Eric thank you so
much for picking up a cup of my book
your one word I really really really
appreciate it man and I hope you're
enjoying doing so thank you guys again
for watching I believe in you I hope we
get seem to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I
will see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot event beretta
[Music]
I truly believe and people throw the
word around dreams it's all about dreams
you know and by the way dreams cost
nothing they're free the hard part is
just keeping them going and please keep
them growing because we're here for one
simple reason he believed in the dream I
believed in the dream and our dreams
come true and there's no reason every
one of yours can't either
thank you very much sounds so cheesy but
it's employer reason for me I heard send
believe in somebody really want
something and really has been brilliant
or hard to it because you can make
everything be very very close now so
yeah
cost you the full your dreams spends
much time you can try to improve get
better they're good things never too
late to learn new things for me still
every day I get to learn new things live
that's the fun thing
you never know everything every single
morning Monday through Fridays at 9:00
a.m. I host a live call-in radio show on
Sirius satellite radio it's called make
it happen with Mel Robbins and the thing
that's been so crazy about that show is
every single person that calls me on
that show they call in because they're
feeling stuck in their lives and they're
resigned about their ability to change
their lives and I'm not talking about
people that are nuts I'm talking about
successful people like you and me that
just somehow got stuck in their lives
and I'm not talking about the old that
are looking for cheesy self-help I'm
talking about people that really want to
figure out how to move themselves
forward and you know I find that so many
of us think that our dreams are
unreachable or unrealistic and it's just
so sad I mean people think that their
dreams disappear and if that's what you
think
congratulations you're officially stuck
and the truth is that our dreams are
always there and they don't ever give up
on us we give up on them but here's the
secret if you just force yourself and I
mean force because I know damn well none
of you want to do anything about this
and I also know you're sitting there
like yeah the self-help crap this is
for me but if you just force yourself to
take a couple small steps there's always
a surprise